i'm a big fan of both of your work
um so and this is a great movie so this
is fantastic
um let me uh i want to jump right on in
and say i'm a huge fan of soderbergh and
i love the
learning about the behind the scenes of
the making of a movie so
what can each of you say about what
might surprise people to learn about the
making of a soderbergh film
stephen is a
detailed genius that you know
as brandon was saying before it's
it it's i mean he's not just directing
the movie from
an objective perspective he's involved
i mean when i say involved i mean
details as he says pic what pictures are
on the wall you know
not what you're wearing but why you are
wearing it
you know those kinds of things um you
know you're holding
i had a cane you know and we went
through several canes before i got the
cane that i
used and finally in the movie because
it not only was the cane
to walk with but what color was it how
did it go with my suit
and why would i choose it and so those
are these kinds of details it's
wonderful working with them
stephen works with such certainty it's
almost as if the film already exists
clearly in his imagination and he's
really there
on the day just to render it into
existence
by shooting it his confidence with
moving a very light camera sticking it
in glove boxes of old cars and
under tables and wherever it needed to
be so we could move very quickly and get
a lot done in very few takes
is just a testament to how confident he
is as a filmmaker
and furthermore the the result is
a film that's exciting very cool
stylized
and socially relevant um in its themes
and
uh and the genre of it is i think
undeniably
one that of the world-class filmmakers
working today that's
that soderbergh excels with 100
um one of the things i loved about ed
solomon's script was everything
but about being specific i would say
that it's the way it weaves in real
world events
with these small time criminals if you
will for both of you can you talk about
what you responded to with the script
what you're excited for people to see i
watch a lot of movies
and this film has action suspense and a
lot of different things in it
and so it keeps you he hooks you and he
keeps you going and stays ahead of the
audience
but what i like about great movies and
you know until historically also
is its ability to hook you humanly
you know it's like he takes your
humanity into it
and once he has you he takes you along
doesn't let you go
and so i think the this film had all of
the elements of an action type of
genre film and but at the same time you
felt something for the people that were
in it
in mob boss films with a genre about
gangsters and there being a big prize
and everyone having their eyes on it in
this film
everyone has their eyes on a different
prize but
surprised and there's one after the next
they just keep rolling by
stories end you learn that the real
prize
was the suppression of a technology that
could have
done our environment a good a great deal
of good had it been instituted in
automobiles
some 25 years before car companies
suppressed its existence and that's
the catalytic converter
a precious piece of an automobile that
um leaves us all breathing a little bit
cleaner air these days
that would have done well to have been
put in some 25 years before it was
mandated uh in the in only the early
1970s in this picture set in 54.
so it it leaves you learning something
and
it's not just an aha but um wow
there's some authenticity to what we're
doing in spite of it being a very
you know fantastic gangster film that's
got anti-heroes and everyone getting
their comeuppance and
plenty of surprises um it really it
really challenges the viewer
as bill's made a point over and over to
to think that you're not going to stay
ahead of this director he's going to
keep you
he's going to keep you guessing i have
to stop there
again big fan of both of your work thank
you so much for giving me your time
thank you